das impfen in der schweiz protestieren
sie dagegen mit kuhglocken
ausgerechnet mit kuhglocken wir machen
uns auf die spuren suchen
lützelflüh im emmental hier begann alles
im
neunzehnten jahrhundert lebte im
pfarrhaus zu lützelflüh ein mann der
seine zeitgenossen für unbelehrbare
hielt
einer der bedeutendsten autoren seiner
zeit jeremias gotthelf im hauptberuf
fach daneben war er journalist volks
aufklärer romanautor
einst beauftragte ihm die stadt bern
eine schrift gegen den aberglauben zu
verfassen gotthelf sagte da steckt viel
mehr drin so entstand sein umfangreicher
roman anne baby omega es ist die
geschichte einer impfgegner ring sowie
ist eine dumme frau hätte die rhi nehmen
zu lassen so wäre alles das nicht aber
so seid ihr zur rechten zeit könnt ihr
nichts tun und wenn dann alles vertuscht
ist durch eure schuld so soll der doktor
alles wiedergutmachen
oder hast du da oben sagen sich
die geschichte einer unbelehrbaren
andere zeiten gleiche probleme
anna baby will ihren sohn bei du nicht
den zu lassen sie misstraut den normalen
letzten sie geht zu kuschen holt dort
mittel er kommt an die grenzen des todes
aber sie ist unbelehrbar und sie das
durch und anna baby macht das wieder mit
dem enkel den sie vergöttert da macht
sie wieder die gleichen fehler und dort
jobbt sie mit hilfe der kurdische das
kleine enkelkind zu tode
für bringen viele dinge in die welt
milch und käse beständigkeit und und
gucken
der englische arzt edward jenner wollte
am ende des achtzehnten jahrhunderts die
pocken besiegen eine furchtbare
krankheit mit hohen todeszahlen
jenner injizierte einem achtjährigen das
sekret einer coupon unter die haut der
junge wurde ihm nun ein sieg der
wissenschaft impfen mit kuhpocken
impfgegner gründeten weltweit vereine
sie sagten durch eine pockenimpfung
wachsen einem corner aus dem leibe doch
es half nichts vielerorts wurde die
pockenimpfung im neunzehnten jahrhundert
zur pflicht das impfen wird sozusagen
als große chance der moderne gesehen als
paradebeispiel für den fortschritt und
andererseits natürlich auch bei den
kritikern der moderne oder in
traditionellen gesellschaften oder
regionen dann auch eben als eingriff und
als eindringen der moderne in die in die
heimat und deshalb auch entsprechend
scharf umkämpft impfgegner wegen kühlen
so ein käse von der kuh kommt nur gutes
das sieht man auch in der schaukäserei
des emmentals die kuh gibt uns milch für
den emmentaler sie gab uns einen
impfstoff gegen die pocken und liefert
den stoff für einen großen roman von
jeremias gotthelf die käserei in der
freude nicht umsonst wurde sogar eine
emmentaler variation nach ihm gott helfe
die impfgegner von heute sie wären für
ihn unbelehrbare gewesen
und immer noch bringt man kühe mit ins
spiel das mit dem impfen eric bis heute
die schweizer an fasnacht vertreibt oder
streichelt man mit kuhglocken die bösen
geister von den bergen herr corona
gegner haben diesen brauch der kadaver
sei erlaubt für ihre zwecke kopiert so
wird zumindest verhindert es nicht
für heinrich schütz ist klar jeremias
gotthelf erklärt die gegenwart
es ist 11 gleich wie heute finde ich
eigentlich kann man die situation der
pocken zeit im neunzehnten jahrhundert
gut übertragen auf die korona zeit
wer gotthelf liest kann damit böse
geister vertreiben
[Musik]
eigentlich hieß er albert beziehungs und
schrieb unter pseudonym man hat ihn
unweit seines pfarrhauses beerdigt
[Musik]
von dort aus kann er predigen gegen die
unbelehrbarkeit der welt
[Musik]